clock a dean if you want to go
as Aid work goes it doesn't get more
dangerous than this
Chris parry's scene on the front line
and back moods the most perilous place
in Ukraine
the former running coach Sprints to the
building where he tells elderly
ukrainians to take cover
and just a week ago in one of the last
videos he explains his mission
uh so I'm an evacuation driver I receive
requests from family members who've
asked us to go and collect their
relatives
the 28 year old's now been missing along
with fellow volunteer Andrew Bagshaw
who's 48 for several days
freelance journalist Daphne westdorpe
took this picture of Chris who'd got
stuck in the winter mud just before they
both disappeared they'll do hope you
know I hope for a miracle uh that either
they're stuck in the basement somewhere
or that they're attracted by the
Russians at least they will be alive and
they could you know things like uh like
trade it you know the word
um but yeah it doesn't look good at this
point because solidar is pretty much
it's just not possible to go there
anymore so yeah it's a
it's hoping for a miracle I would say
Chris Parry drove to Ukraine in early
March with a van of Aid in November and
December he regularly posted video on
social media of him rescuing civilians
from the city of back moot
his operation was based in kramatosk
around 80 kilometers away
Chris and Andrew were last seen there on
Friday heading to the front line in
solidar
they were reported missing by the police
on Saturday
and the reports coming out of the area
do not sound good the salt mining city's
been turned into a smoking Wasteland by
some of the fiercest fighting this war
has seen
everything is completely destroyed
there's almost no life left and
thousands of their people are lost the
whole land under solidar is covered in
the corpses of the Invaders and in scars
from the blows
but it is thought Ukrainian troops have
been pushed out of most of the
settlements after a massive Russian
offensive
it's hard to know exactly what's
happening but moscow's forces are hoping
their grip on the city will allow them
to strengthen their attacks on the
already besieged neighboring city of
back moots solidar is almost certainly
now cut off from ukrainian-controlled
territory
the foreign office says it's offering
support to both men's families
Alex Rossi Sky News eastern Ukraine